today on the Matt wall show the left
claims that there is a right-wing book
Banning movement growing across the
country but they're lying as usual look
at the facts today also the CDC
recommends that the kova vaccine be
added to your child's regular
immunization schedule Elon Musk plans to
fire the majority of Twitter employees
I'm taking my what is a woman tour to
Berkeley and expecting a very open and
welcoming environment when I get there
in our daily cancellation a man faces
the internet outrage mob after
suggesting that men and women experience
depression differently the horror all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
here at the DIY we are committed to
winning back the culture losing is just
not an option there's too much riding on
it and part of that means supporting
businesses who whose values align with
our own which is why I'm very excited to
tell you that we've teamed up with Black
Rifle Coffee Company many of you know
about Black Rifle already it's a veteran
founded and operated Coffee Company
who've made it their admission to hire
10 000 veterans and they're well on
their way one of the many laudable
things Black Rifle does is they help
service members successfully transition
from the military into entrepreneurship
and they're constantly giving back to
veteran foundations as well as law
enforcement and First Responders by
purchasing from Black Rifle Coffee
Company you are directly supporting the
military service Community what about
the coffee itself well that's important
too and I can tell you it's bold strong
and really good Black Rifle is very
selective about where they Source their
coffee beans from and they're
disciplined when it comes to ensuring
the freshness of every bag so go to
Black riflecoffee.com and use promo code
Walsh for 10 off your first order or
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription the subscription gives you
free shipping on on all coffee Club
orders Early Access to Club deals and
promotions and special discounts from
their partner Brands that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code walls
for 10 off your first order or when you
sign up to become a coffee Club member
Black Rifle coffee supporting veterans
and America's coffee
well today is the day shortly after we
finish filming this episode I'll be
heading downtown to the Capitol Building
here in Nashville for our rally to end
child mutilation we are expecting a
large turnout perhaps a significant
presence of counter protesters also I
don't know but we also can't know for
sure exactly what to expect because
there's never been a rally of this size
and scale on this issue before as far as
I know we are building a movement we're
starting from the ground floor
because someone has to do it and we've
decided that it may as well be us now
there is of course
plenty of value in talking and uh
delivering opinions making arguments the
kinds of things that we do here in
conservative media
every day but the problem is that in
conservative media for so long that's
essentially all we have ever done
and I'm just kind of tired of only
talking it's time to take action and
that's what we're going to do uh this
afternoon the fight of course doesn't
end today just like it doesn't start
today but this is the beginning of a
necessary phase in the fight the phase
where we actually
take to the street show up in person the
sort of thing that the left has been
very good at doing for a long time and
been doing it basically unopposed
because it's not enough to to post about
these sorts of things online we have to
be a physical presence visible to the
world
now
there's certainly risk in that because
the more you put yourself out there the
more you open yourself up to all sorts
of potential consequences but I'm more
than ready to take the risk and I hope
you are too
although there isn't as much risk as you
might think not if we actually really
mobilize because we have we have numbers
on our side
to a to an enormous degree in fact the
daily wire has this report today quote a
new poll found that nearly 80 percent of
American voters believe that minors
should be required to wait until they
are adults to pursue transgender
procedures
the national survey conducted by
Convention of States action and
partnership with the Trafalgar group
pulled over a thousand likely 2022
election voters in October when asked if
they believed underage minor should be
required to wait until they're adults to
use puberty blockers and undergo
permanent sex change procedures the poll
found that 78.7 percent of all
respondents comprising Democrats
Republicans and nonpartisan affiliations
said that they should in fact wait the
overwhelming majority of Republicans and
independent voters oppose gender change
treatments for minors while Democrats
were divided
96.8 percent of Republican voters 84.6
percent of independent voters and 53.2
percent of Democrats which is still a
majority said that miners should wait
until they are adults to pursue medical
transition
okay so that's 80 of Americans and all
you will not find eighty percent
agreement
on almost anything
you probably can't find eighty percent
of Americans who will agree that the sun
rose this morning
and on this subject
on protecting children from gender
ideology indoctrination mutilation abuse
there is as close to unanimous consensus
as you will ever get on any issue
and yet these atrocities
have happened all across the country
they continue to happen the gender
ideologues have been operating again
nearly unopposed for years
in spite of the fact that hundreds of
millions of Americans actually do oppose
them
that's because the opposition doesn't
mean anything and has no effect if it's
purely theoretical and abstract
if we don't mobilize if we don't convert
it into action we remain powerless even
with an army of hundreds of millions
behind us
this is about actually using the power
that we have there is an opportunity for
a broad vast
enormous and even yes diverse Coalition
on this on this issue and there's also
evidence that the Coalition is already
coming together take what's happening in
Dearborn Michigan for example Dearborn
is a traditionally a democratic
stronghold it's also a heavily Muslim
area with Arab Americans comprising
nearly about 50 of the City's population
I think now given historical voting
habits it's not the kind of place where
Democrats have had to worry about Mass
protest movements challenging them
you don't have to worry about anyone
challenging them from from the right or
even the left
and yeah that is exactly what's happened
the Muslim Community in Dearborn has
mobilized showing up in huge numbers at
school board meetings and at rallies to
oppose LGBT indoctrination in the school
system there
now this uh this particular round of
backlash was provoked by pornographic
and sexually explicit LGBT propaganda
which had been beta available to
children in the local school system one
of the books at the center of the
Firestorm is called uh you might have
heard this title before because it's
come up in other places at school bar
meetings but the book is called this
book is gay and it contains not only the
promotion of but also the extremely
graphic description of gay sex
and the content is
so graphic it's so explicit it's so
beyond the bounds of what could remotely
be considered appropriate for children
that I can't read any of it to you or
even describe it
but I will tell you it was more than
enough to inspire the largely Muslim
Community to take action and at a rally
a few days ago one local father got up
at the microphone and uh made his case
and made it I think quite powerfully
listen to this
I just want to thank you everybody for
coming out my name is
I'm nothing but a concerned parent in
Dearborn Michigan
um guys we want to make something clear
okay
we want to leave the politics out of
this if you're on Facebook all you see
is fear of mongering political rhetoric
that this is book Banning censorship
homophobic all that is protecting our
children we we
parents
we have concerned parents in Dearborn
are not tired
to the right when it comes to this issue
and we're not going to be used as pawns
for any Organization for their own
agenda right here it's like our children
foreign
do not fall for the Trap because that's
what they want they're trying to smear
us they're trying to control the
narrative they're trying to say this is
homophobic listen there's a there's a
book there's a book that was banned and
what's called this book is gay and I
tell you if the book was called this
book is straight we're still gonna go
after it because it's teaching kids it's
teaching kids how to go online and have
sexual intercourse with others on the
internet this is wrong
United Sports Grace is sexually explicit
material
there's a there's a poster right here to
my right
there's a poster right here to my right
that I had them cover up I as an adult
and 33 year old adult told them cover it
up because I'm embarrassed to look at
this you think I want a 13 year old to
look at it this is ridiculous any semi
decent human being homosexual or
heterosexual knows when they look in the
mirror that kids should not be exposed
to this stop trying to control the
rhetoric stop trying to make it as you
guys are the victims because this has
nothing to do with it we as parents who
are raising our children are responsible
for our children our schools will not
indoctrinate our children the
progressive Dogma from the top down that
has public schools in a total will not
indoctrine our children
amen and it's as simple as that he's a
father
doesn't want his children sexually
indoctrinated in the school system
that's it of course according to the
left this makes him literally Hitler uh
which Speaking of which here's a liberal
white woman at a school board meeting uh
in Dearborn trying to explain that the
the largely Muslim population
that don't want their kids exposed to
graphic gay sex are indeed just like
Hitler
I am not in favor of banning any books
in Dearborn if parents do not want their
children to read a book they should not
allow them to do that but to voice their
views of one group of citizens and the
rest of Dearborn doesn't work either
this is what Hitler did and we all know
how that worked out
oh yeah we know how that worked out
um first you're preventing teachers from
talking to sixth graders about anal sex
next thing you know there's a holocaust
that's what we're supposed to believe
anyway
of course she says that um
she doesn't want the views of the
anti-porn for children factions to be
foisted on everybody else but she does
want the views of the other side voiced
it in the end this is a conflict of
viewpoints there's one side says that
children should be sexually
indoctrinated in the school system the
other side says that they should not
both are attempting to impose that point
of view
okay if you're if you're involved in an
issue on either side of it you have a
point of view that you were trying to
get across
you are advocating
and it's up to each side to make the
case for themselves
something that these groomers are unable
to do which is why they settle for
wildly misrepresenting their opponents
indeed the whole notion that parents are
calling for book Bans
is ridiculous these are not book bands
no school in the world okay contains
every book ever published schools can
only catalog and assign and include in
their curriculum a finite number of
books like if all the books ever made a
small sliver of a percentage
of those books will be in the school and
will be part of the curriculum and so
it's just a matter of deciding which
books do we include
like we can include
.0001 of all books and all the rest are
excluded
that doesn't mean that the 99.99 have
been banned they've been burned at
censorship
no the books that are not included
haven't been banned haven't been
censored
they've simply been judged irrelevant or
inappropriate for the school
yesterday Carla Hernandez a running mate
for Charlie Christ in Florida uh posted
a video
where she goes through what she
describes as a banned math book and she
captions the video today's chalk book
talk deals with the ridiculous book
Banning happening in Florida remember
knowledge is power and we should have
the freedom to learn now I should note
that the Tweet currently up on her page
is her second attempt to tweet this in
the first tweet which was quickly
deleted she misspelled the word
knowledge
which is hilarious but that's not the
biggest issue or the biggest issue is
that she's just straight up lying about
why this book was quote unquote banned
which again it was not banned just isn't
being used in the school system but
here's what she says listen to this
and good afternoon everyone welcome to
this week's chalkboard talk today from
the desk of Miss Hernandez today I want
to talk about something that turned out
to be a little bit controversial this
past year with Governor Ron DeSantis it
was the Banning of books did you know
that Florida is the second state with
the most banned books in the entire
country yes what an awful statistic we
are the second state which means we are
the ones that
um keep kids or people from having
access to knowledge and we know that
knowledge is power so I did a little bit
of research trying to figure out why
math was controversial this year and why
we met we banned math books or not we
let me say why he did why he banned math
books so I got this math book
um it is a fifth grade math book in our
Public Schools
um and I started to do some research as
you as you will notice we did a lot of
notes there's a lot of controversy in
this book yes the controversy is real so
let me show you some examples of the
controversy
example number one
Juan gets six dollars for his weekly
allowance and spends four his sister
Tina gets seven dollars
girls shouldn't make more money than
Juan we know why this was banned example
number two
dad has a flower shop boys flower shop
we're not doing that
okay first of all she can't even speak
let alone right
um so this is someone who probably
should have spent more time
reading reading textbooks herself second
state with the most banned books you
mean it's the state with the second most
banned books is what you're trying to
say
even though again that's not true
everything else she says there is an
enormous load of nonsense
to be clear she's she's simply making
this up so they went through the book
and they just invented reasons why it
was banned
it made them up at a whole cloth
I guess that's probably a lot of fun
they picked up the math book and they
flipped through it and they found and
they took copious amounts of notes
and they came up with fantasy scenarios
and fantasy reasons why the right would
be supposedly uh objecting to the book
They're hoping that you're stupid enough
to believe that Florida banned a math
book
because it depicts a man owning a flower
shop
yeah that's in the law isn't it that's
somewhere in the law maybe that's in the
don't say gay law which doesn't exist
either but uh
since the law doesn't exist I guess any
it could say anything
yeah it's somewhere in there I gotta
check maybe it's on the third page of
the it's uh it says that uh you're not
allowed to mention uh men owning flower
shops in any textbook
now in reality this math book and others
like it were rejected from the
curriculum
because they include gratuitous
political indoctrination which has
nothing to do with anything she just
read there so here's one example I'm not
sure if it's from the book that she's
using because she doesn't tell us which
book it is but this gives you an idea of
the kind of thing that Florida is
guarding against so as an NBC news
report shows
one math book was rejected because it
contained a chart which purports to
measure racial Prejudice by political
identification showing you which
political identification is the most
racist and I think you know where this
is going to end the chart of course
claims that conservatives are the most
racially prejudiced now why does that
disqualify the book because it is a
blatant attempt to smuggle partisan
propaganda into a math lesson
it's also not true it's false the only
way that you can justify the claim that
conservatives are more racially
prejudiced than liberals is if you
discount from the start all forms of
anti-white racial prejudice
the only way because the left especially
in modern times is wildly anti-white
racist and it's it's fully mainstream
and fully accepted
and they also support policies actual
systemic discrimination against white
people through the form of affirmative
action and other quote diversity
policies and that sort of thing
so the only way that you can look at
that and then still say that well
conservatives are more racially
prejudiced is if you just
declare from the start that all forms of
anti-white prejudice don't count because
it's not racist of course the book does
have that view it does Discount that
because the left believes that white
people by definition cannot be the
victims of racism this belief is a core
element of critical race Theory critical
race Theory then is in the book
propaganda lies
included in a math lesson
it's gratuitous it's irrelevant
it's erroneous
that's why Florida schools don't include
the book in their curriculum
the other side lies about the reasons
because all they have are lies
they are losing the argument
and they know it that's what this all
comes down to they're losing the
argument of Florida they're losing it in
Dearborn Michigan
they're losing it here in Nashville
and we're going to demonstrate that
today
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
uh you consider to be your your family's
values Faith Church on Sunday does your
family believe in in serving
did you vaccinate your kids or did you
say hell no how does your family Define
men and women what kind of value do they
put on human life your children look to
you to Define their values and their
perspectives of the world but what if
you weren't here to do that for them to
help in that way in the event that you
die you will ensure the values that you
hold dear are are upheld by your kids
how are you going to do that well you'll
do that with epic will they can help
with that a will let you determine who
will raise your kids in the event that
you die before them and before you're
done raising them this is a big deal and
it's your responsibility as a parent
it's why we at the daily wire have
partnered with epic will so take five
minutes say go to epicwill.com and use
promo code Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package but more
importantly you're doing it so that I
know that you did it because I'm keeping
track so you are accountable to me is
the point so that I know that you took
this crucial step towards doing the
right thing and taking care of your
family I know who you are I'll be
checking epicwill.com promo code Walsh
no excuses get it done
all right let's begin with this news
from Politico headline CDC advisors
recommend adding coveted shots to
routine immunization schedules for kids
and adults the cdc's independent vaccine
advisors voted 15-0
big surprise there Thursday to add most
covid-19 vaccines offered in the U.S to
the childhood Adolescent and adult
immunization schedules the immunization
schedules which are updated every fall
before going into effect the following
year consolidate all the cdc's vaccine
recommendations into one document for
states that use them as guidance for
school entry requirements and busy
Physicians the additions formalize
recommendations that's an interesting
qualifier actually
there are guidance for School
requirements and busy Physicians
why do you include busy what does effect
what is the fact that the Physicians are
busy what does that have to do with any
how does that relate how is that
relevant to the the recommended
immunization schedule
well I know how it relates is what
they're saying is that uh well
Physicians they don't have time to look
at people on a case-by-case basis they
don't have time to consider what you
actually need medically and so uh they
need they need just broad strokes and
they're going to give the same shots and
the same drugs to everybody
that's what they're saying
anyway the additions formalized
recommendations the CDC has already made
on covet vaccination individual
individuals ages six months and older
for shots that the FDA has approved or
has authorized for emergency use code
vaccine inclusion on the schedules don't
constitute mandates particularly for
school children which are the purview of
states localities or jurisdictions
depending on local laws still the
committee's vote sparked controversy and
debate on social media about what the
additions mean for vaccine requirements
after Fox news's Tucker Carlson asserted
Tuesday that the CDC would trigger
mandates for students
oh Tucker Carlson asserted that that's
his claim
well he may have asserted it but uh
that's because Tucker Carlson you know
unlike many of his critics has a brain
and he's able to observe things and so
he has noticed that when the CDC
recommends something it almost
immediately becomes a mandate in many
different states
and localities that's that's that's the
way that's that's how the pipeline works
yeah the CDC can't itself mandate
anything
but once they have their recommendations
it becomes a mandate that's not that's
not speculation it's not a theory he's
not looking in a crystal ball
all you have to do is look at recent
history to know that's the case
so pretty soon this will become a
mandate for entry into schools and so on
um fortunately my kids don't go to
public school so I don't have to worry
about that because when it comes to
giving my kids the covet vaccine my
answer has not changed and my answer in
summary is that you can go to hell
kindly no offense I mean that in the
plightest way but you can still go to
hell
you know my here's the thing my kids
have had covid
I think like a dozen times probably I
mean who really knows because we don't
generally test for it and uh but they
get covered symptoms otherwise known as
a cold you know otherwise known as cold
symptoms and they have the sniffles
and then they're fine
and that's it
and we go about our lives
you know vaccinate for that
we go
recommend which turns into a mandate for
a vaccine against the sniffles
for kids which is all it has ever been
from the very beginning
so one of the one of the few things
that we knew about covid from the very
beginning and that has and that has
remained unchanged
is that this has very little impact on
kids
and yet there are still parents that are
lining up to to put these drugs into
their kids
unconscionable
this is from yaf it says members of the
University of Alabama's generation
action chapter are planning to protest
Matt Walsh's upcoming what is a woman's
screening event on campus hosted by the
University's Young Americans for a
freedom chapter
um Ashley Whitmire president of the
planned parenthood-sponsored student
organization wrote in a group chat I
know many of you are disheartened and
angry about Matt Walsh's visit to campus
as we are on the executive uh we have
been in touch with other like-minded
orgs and together we are organizing a
protest
members of the app chapter caught
several leftist vandals splashing water
on one of their sidewalk chalk event
announcements
um and then other things as well and
they're calling so it's the same story
they're calling for the University to to
put a stop to the talk and all that I
bring this up because
um a couple reasons
one is that we were we were just talking
about
banning and censorship and all of that
and as I explained we have to continue
explaining
um
what we're talking about doing or or
what's being advocated for in the school
systems in Dearborn else Place elsewhere
this is not a book ban
except unless you want to say that again
99.99 of all books ever written are
banned quote unquote in every school
in the world
because they can't all be included
you know in in Florida
uh the NBC report said that they said
something like uh I forget what the
exact number was but I don't know 60 or
70 out of a potential 150 plus math
books have been quote banned otherwise
known as rejected
are we going to have 150 math textbooks
we have 150 different math curriculums
circulating out there
no you have to select a few there's all
there can only be so so many that are in
the school system
and you're going to have standards by
which you selected it's just this is
really a question the debate is really
what should the standard be it's not
whether there should be one what is the
standard what are you looking for in a
textbook
so anyway that's not a man
for the people that are using that word
uh they of course are are strong
advocates for actual bands for example
every college campus that I go to they
want to ban me from the campus and very
often they fail at doing it but that's
what they want to do they want me banned
from the campus not just me any other
conservative speaker they want us banned
not allowed
like and they'll use that word actually
they're not just trying to ban books
they're trying to ban people
Banning and censorship they want to uh
you know what what where do you find
that in our in our culture you find that
social media
people with opposing views they want
them banned from social media platforms
de-platformed
that's what Banning and censorship looks
like
uh speaking of leftist students being
upset this is also a good time to
announce as we as I announced yesterday
um on Twitter very excited that um I can
finally make it official that on
November 17th as our what is a woman
College Tour continues I will be going
to Berkeley
um so we will be we will be screening
the film and I'll be speaking at
Berkeley and
I'm looking forward to that now if if
you know this assumes that the
university will there's obviously
already go there already is and is and
it's going to ramp up in the coming
weeks but there's going to be a strong
Push by uh the student Sarah Berkeley to
convince the university to shut us down
I hope the university Stands Strong I
can't claim that I'm
not necessarily confident they will but
if they withstand that pressure then we
will be at Berkeley on November 17th
showing the film and I'll be talking and
um why are we going to Berkeley well
I mean are we going there because it'll
be hilarious to see the Epic freak out
meltdown temper tantrum yeah that is
part of it I I can't deny that that's
part of my motivation I do enjoy that
but it's also just on principle
yeah because we said we're going to
Berkeley and I've heard from other
conservatives you're going hey why are
you going there you sure about that you
sure you want to go to Berkeley don't
you know what they what they do and when
conservatives show up there
yeah that's all the more reason why I
want to go just in principle
there there should not be any American
University
I don't care how far left it is I don't
care if it is Berkeley there should not
be any American University that that is
insulated from
not even just opposing viewpoints but
the truth as I'm always emphasizing the
students that try to shut down our talks
they're not they're not nearly shutting
down opposing viewpoints they are doing
that
but more to the point they're shutting
down the truth because what we are
talking about what I am there to talk
about are basic
fundamental scientific truths about life
and there should not be I just reject
the notion
that there is or ought to be
any University in the country it was
supposedly an institution of Higher
Learning that is insulated from the
truth where you can't you can't go on
the campus and speak basic truths I
don't I reject that and so if you tell
me that well you know
you can say these things on these plays
but you can't go to that University and
speak those truths when you tell me that
then I'm going to say well that's
exactly where I'm going
all right this is from the daily wire
says billionaire Elon Musk will
reportedly gut Twitter with massive cuts
when he takes over getting rid of the
overwhelming majority of the company The
Washington Post reported that musk told
prospective investors that he plans to
get rid of nearly 75 percent of
Twitter's 7 500 workers whittling the
company down to a skeleton staff of just
over 2 000. the report said that even if
the musks even if musk's acquisition of
Twitter somehow does not go through
large cuts are still expected as the
current people running the company plan
to get rid of roughly 25 percent of the
company's staff so they were already
planning on making big cuts of 25
percent
Elon Musk is saying let's triple that
and get rid of 75 the report said that
the plan cuts by Twitter's Executives
helped to explain why the company wanted
to sell to musk once he made the offer
the social media platform had been
fighting musk and Court over his attempt
to cancel the previous buy so we know
about all that so 75 is what their what
their uh what Elon Musk supposedly
is planning to cut I think this is great
news
I don't generally make a habit of
celebrating job loss
um unless it's at Twitter
or if it's at like Planned Parenthood
or uh if it's anywhere else in big Tech
or if it's in the federal government
so maybe I do make a habit of
celebrating job loss but anyway this is
great news because because
primarily because absolutely gutting the
staff
is the only real way to make the woke
censorship and all of that go away
and this is one of the reasons why the
media when they're reporting on this
they're they're panicking over it
because the weather's not going to be
enough there's going to be misin for
quote unquote misinformation and hate
speech all over Twitter there's not
gonna be enough people there to put out
all these fires
that's exactly the point
you know I've already declared my
intention which I'm which I still intend
on this my intention to go on a
misgendering
spree it's going to be a misgendering
massacre once Elon Musk takes over I'll
just be I'll just be misgendering
everyone
all the time and it'll be great but that
also assumes that the old regime is
actually cleared out
um because if it's not if Elon Musk
takes over and but then almost everyone
else stays in place beneath him then
there's no actual reason to think that
anything changes
and one thing that we know is that it's
very hard
to
change a fundamentally left-wing
institution even from the top
Donald Trump discovered that
and the fundamentally a left-wing
institution in his case was the Federal
Government
but it's very hard to do and the more
people that there are the the bigger the
bureaucracy uh the more difficult it is
so the only way is to go in there and
just clean clean the place out
which fortunately looks like that's what
he is uh
planning to do all right this is from
The Daily Mail
a hospital banned a sex assault victim
from having an operation after she asked
for a all-female nursing care because of
safety concerns over mixed facilities
now the patient a feminist retired
lawyer
um
that is is the daily mails referring to
only as Emma
was told by London's Princess Grace
Hospital that it had to protect staff
from unacceptable distress
so she had been due to have complex
colorectal surgery at the premises on
October 10th and had filled in a
pre-admission form detailing her
requirements Emma who lives in North
London asked for single sex
accommodation and as per her beliefs did
not wish to use pronouns or engage with
such manifestations of gender ideology
she told mail online I was not going to
agree to fill in reams of Hospital
paperwork about my non-existent gender
identity or give my pronouns to anyone
the hospital is one of the only uh one
of only a handful to use the da Vinci
robot which can perform delicate and
complex operations and was selected for
that reason but when she arrived on
October 6 for her clinical pre-op
assessment which involved intimate
procedures what appeared to be a
transgender woman otherwise known as a
man and a blonde wig and makeup opened
the door and made eye contact with her
the encounter prompted her to complain
and to make an urgent extra request for
all female nursing care Emma told mail
online I began to wonder if it was just
a coincidence that this member of the
staff with a gender identity had made
their presence felt to me in such an
inappropriate way during my first visit
I began to suspect that I had been
targeted because my patient records show
that I refused to reuse use pronouns and
wanted Single Sex facilities although I
have no evidence of this then I began to
panic that men would be attending to my
intimate Care at the hospital while I
was immobilized for an entire week
following major surgery
it was a slow draining realization I
felt sick alarm Bells were ringing in my
head I cannot describe the fear that I
felt I cannot rationalize it she wrote
to HCA that that evening underlining her
concerns and her beliefs relating to
gender women's rights Emma cited The
Landmark case
um involving Maya forestator which said
gender critical beliefs were protected
under the equality act and worthy of
respect
okay so that just to summarize from here
so she's at she's at the hospital for
this uh as they put it intimate
procedure
and or she's going to be very you know
sort of vulnerable and she made the
request ahead of time
that she only wants female staff and all
this was was known ahead of time
and uh it ends with the hospital telling
her that well actually we can't honor
that request
because because you know if you if you
want to get the surgery here then we're
going to include men in it who claim
that they're women
because they said it's distressing it's
distressing to the man dressed as a
woman if he's not allowed to be involved
in your procedure
it's distressing to him
and so they end up canceling the
procedure that she desperately needs
okay this is not a cosmetic procedure
this is this is a desperately needed
medical procedure that they canceled
because
she didn't want
you know she wanted her privacy
respective
what they what they told her was you can
have your privacy and your dignity or
you can get the necessary medical
procedure but you can't have all of
those things
this is another one of those cases where
you you see this and and uh
the the Temptation especially on the
right is to make the point right that
the hospital as we as we see so often
the hospital is putting the feelings of
the trans person over the physical
safety and physical well-being of a
woman you know they're putting safety
they're putting feelings over safety and
physical well-being and that's true that
is what they're doing that's the same
thing that happens when they allow men
into women's locker room we see that all
over the place
but when we make this argument it
doesn't it doesn't sink in on the left
and the reason it doesn't sink in is
because before you can even make that
argument you first have to explain
why physical safety and physical
well-being are more important than
feelings because that's not how they see
it I mean they really believe that the
most important thing in life are your
feelings and that is in fact more
important even than your own physical
safety
that's like the only reason that you
exist is is for your feelings the only
reason that anyone else in the world
exists is to affirm and validate your
feelings make you feel better about
yourself that's the way they see it
which is insane and twisted and upside
down
but it's one of the reasons why
sometimes I I think that the the better
argument here
which which by All rights is a worse
argument but kind of arguing on their
terms a little bit using their terms
against them
okay let's take physical safety out of
it then
even though that's obviously more
important than Felix but okay let's put
that aside
so then okay
we have a competition of feelings then
so it's the feeling of this guy
he's going to be distressed if he's not
allowed to be involved
versus the feelings of the woman
she'll be distressed if he is involved
so if feelings are primary which I'm not
admitting or agreeing that they are but
according to you they are so
we've got the males feelings versus the
females feelings
whose feelings come first
well obviously they say that the male's
feelings come first but we should force
them to say that
force them to admit that what you are
saying is that this biological male his
feelings come before the feelings of
this woman
or any woman indeed
all right we uh told you a few days ago
about the bar in Oregon that is uh
planning to feature a child drag queen
and we also told you about this child's
groomers her um and it is apparently a
her this is a girl dressed like a drag
queen dancing for money at bars so we
told you about all that well now we got
an update from Andy no he says um
old Nick's Pub released a statement from
friends and family of the child drag
queen it contains falsehoods about the
report one of the reporters who worked
on this story along with Andy no it says
that she released the name of the child
she did not statement says she's in a
relationship with a proud boy and this
is also false
and here's a little bit where the
statement says it says thanks to a woman
known on Twitter as honey badger mom who
also felt the need to make assumptions
about the situation and released the
name of an 11 year old child to Millions
online we vanellope's family and friends
have decided that it's time to lay the
rumors to rest and and present the facts
in regard to the relationship between
Vanellope and Kelsey metaborin we
realized that we should have made an
earlier made one earlier in the week but
taking care of Vanellope has been our
priority right they're um taking care of
the child Vanellope he's the stage name
taking care of her is their priority
which is why they're putting her up on
stage at bars to dance for money in a
drag outfit
V was made a victim of doxing by Miss
Mrs honey badger mom who was married to
a well-known proud boy which caused her
to be unable to attend school the entire
week due to safety concerns causing
serious stress trauma and anxiety for
the child and family regarding the
relationship between Vanellope and a
well-known and a woman known as Kelsey
metaborin there in fact was no
relationship a relationship Beyond a
professional one metaborin only
interacted with v a total of maybe four
or five times in professional settings
for venues and charity events Mana born
was not a family friend nor was she ever
a mentor for V in the drag world
and then it goes on from there but
that's that's the excuse that they're
offering and I don't doubt by the way
that this child is traumatized and all
that I don't doubt that for a second
but it's you the quote friends and
family that have caused this trauma
and I was also thinking about just just
again
because I wasn't sure about this when we
first talked about the story it wasn't
clear how what what the actual genders
were but now it does seem clear that
that the child is a girl
and and that's
in a way you're tempted to say it's
almost worse now it's not worse they're
equally horrific whether it's a boy or
girl being put in this environment
um it's equally horrific but it's
horrifying in a in a different sort of
way when it's a girl because
when they dress a boy up like a drag
queen and they have them dance around
it's predatory it's sick it's wrong it's
evil it's abusive all the adults
involved should be should be rounded up
put in handcuffs frog marched to prison
and kept there for decades
all that is the case
but they have this excuse you know where
they say well no this is about uh
diversity and expression and breaking
gender barriers and whatever those are
horrible excuses not remotely convincing
or acceptable
but I guess my question is what even is
the excuse for having a girl do this how
do you how do you
your explanation for having a boy do it
is insane
but what is your explanation for having
a girl do it
this is just it's just it's it's simply
straight up burlesque this it's just
like it's a it's a really kind of
straightforward
burlesque performance
by like a 10 year old girl
at a bar with people throwing money at
her
um
and this is what this is what is
happening
somehow cloaked uh you know it's it's
under this umbrella of LGBT expression
it's like it's got nothing even to do
with that
and if it did that still obviously
wouldn't make it okay but it's it's like
not it's
it just defies defies explanation and
there is no real explanation they can
give for any of this because uh because
if they were to be honest about it
um you know what they're doing is
they're sexualizing kids and they're
doing it on purpose and that's of course
what the intention is all right let's
get now to the comment section
[Music]
again
[Music]
you know uh chain stores they have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers but the
good thing about rockauto.com is the
prices are the same for everybody and
they're reliably low for everybody
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices uh based on what they think the
market will bear like Airlines do
rockauto.com is a family-owned business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com for uh auto
and body parts from hundreds of
Manufacturers they have everything you
need from engine control modules brake
parts tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet it's all there whether this is
for your classic or your daily driver
you can get everything you need with
just a few easy clicks to leverage
straight to your door the rockauto.com
catalog is very easy to navigate best of
all most important thing to me is that
the prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low again for everybody amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need at
rockauto.com so go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck uh rockauto.com and be sure
to write Walsh in there how did you hear
about a spot box so they know that I
sent you
Noah Hecker says hearing Matt read the
description of a weeb warms my cold
heart well there's not a lot of
heartwarming moments on the show I don't
think so I'm glad that I could provide
that for you Zimmer handcrafted says
Matt didn't even mention the suggestion
to put birth control in the water from
the jaff memo uh yeah I mean there's a
whole lot more in the draft number that
we talked about yesterday to start the
show and just go online and Google Jeff
memo and you'll see you can get a PDF of
it look at it yourself uh yeah there's a
there's a lot in there and
um
you know there are
it's you I guess you decide what's more
kind of terrifying it's the stuff that
was suggested that didn't happen like
compulsory abortions for out of wedlock
pregnancy that has not happened yet
so is that what's more terrifying or or
all the stuff in there that they really
did
um no it's a judgment call out of the
way
Professor chip says
Matt I just got to say you're completely
correct that the countless planets in
the known universe have a purpose for
being there and undoubtedly Harbor life
Knowles needs to be canceled if he
hasn't been already well of course he
has been and there was just another I'm
glad you brought that up because I had
to I couldn't get to it in the five
headlines but there was just another
story
and um The Daily wire reports well maybe
I'll mention it now
it says various veteran pilots flying
over the Pacific Ocean in August and
September have claimed that they saw
UFOs flying in circles above them in the
night sky
okay
so once again
you've got
these Pilots are saying we're seeing
UFOs and you can see some of the footage
and it's just it is obviously crafts
these are some kind of vehicles that are
behaving in ways that seem to defy what
human technology can do and I I see I
just don't buy I know the the
explanation that most people go with is
that well this is enemy technology
drones or whatever I don't buy it
because for one thing if if the if we
had an adversary here on Earth that had
that kind of Technology
um I think they'd be doing more by now
than just like flying around in the sky
and putting on a show for us
so it is 100 confirmed to be aliens
without a question
um
let's see
tyrannic Cubone says I'm impressed it
seems that Matt has refined his argument
against pornography to include the very
reason that I had that I have uh given
up for oh to include the very reason I
have given for using it and has come up
with a far better metaphor than I have I
never said I thought pornography is
better than relationship but if you have
to choose between dying of starvation
and dying of malnutrition you'll choose
the option that will buy you more time
at least that's the calculation at first
but like he said you're also more
inclined to give up pursuing a real
relationship once you're no longer
starving for one right that's exactly
the point is that
it becomes
um it ends up becoming a substitute for
a real human relationship and it numbs
you know without pornography and without
all this without the hyper sexualization
in the culture
um you know even without all that of
course as as men and women too but
speaking about men
you know you have this
desires natural desire for as we said
yesterday for for female companionship
and historically right that's what
drives you to find a woman you get into
a relationship you marry her you start a
family
you know and that's that's the engine
that gets you going in that direction
but
with pornography and all the sex
everywhere it it numbs a man's
[Music]
um
you know
instincts and his Desires in that in
that direction
all right
Kristen Pierre says this whole
conversation about reclining the seat on
an airplane is being talked about as if
seats on an airplane recline more than
an inch
Stephen Mackey says you buy the seat the
seat reclines you can recline the seat
end of story
Timothy says maybe Matt has forgotten
what it's like to be a normal person who
can't afford to fly in first class if
the seat that I paid for and Coach is a
reclining seat then I have the right to
recline it
Rudy says if the seat allows you to
recline it then you can recline it okay
all of you I unders yes you can you have
the right to if I was in charge you
wouldn't even have the legal right but
uh under the current regime you do so
you have the legal right to you have the
ability to yeah you can physically
recline the seat doesn't mean you go
okay
okay I can I can I can physically make
movements with my I can move my arms
around I can physically make a punching
movement with my arm
does that make it acceptable then to go
just walk him and punch you in the face
just
and I punch you in the face can I say
well what do you mean my arm moves like
that if my arm can do that then I should
be able to do it
and yes it's exactly the same thing
morally reclining your seed is like
punching the person you know it's not
even punch like spitting in their face
showing total disregard for them
I guess I just have more maybe in the
end I have more empathy and compassion
although I am you know it's like when
you can sit in first class then it's
this isn't as much of an issue so I do
highly recommend that
uh history and headline says what is the
most important issue we're currently
facing well I think we just I think we
just stumbled on it it's uh
should we recline our seats on the
airplane and it's all the more urgent
now now that I see that you know so many
people there's so much there's so much
Pro reclining propaganda out there that
we have to battle
quick look at the weather liberal tears
have been falling all over the country
and Illinois and Florida at my what is a
woman campus tour Washington DC at the
overturning of Roe v Wade and with
election day on the horizon we can
expect 2022 to be one of the wettest
years on record that's why for the first
time we're making the iconic daily wire
leftist tears tumbler available to
everybody so we can catch all these
leftist tears don't go let any of them
go to waste Forge in the fires of the
hottest takes This Magnificent vessel is
now just thirty dollars don't miss out
on the heavy tear fall go to uh
dailywire.com Tumblr and get your
leftist tears tumbler right now now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
earlier in the month a man named Adam
Lane Smith tweeted his thoughts about
depression Smith identifies himself as a
retired psychotherapist turned
attachment specialist not really sure
what an attachment specialist is exactly
but I know that um this one had an
interesting thought to share about
depression he wrote quote
male depression is nearly always a
result of learned helplessness but
Healthcare Providers treat it like
female depression and they try to make a
man feel loved instead of powerful
that's what he said now this take as you
might expect provoked a fair amount of
outrage and mockery so just a quick
sampling of some of the replies someone
said LMFAO this is the dumbest thing
I've read all day why are we gendering
depression like I a female do not have
depression because I don't feel loved I
have depression because my brain doesn't
make enough serotonin
quick note here no that's not why you
feel depressed the serotonin theory of
depression has been exposed as a myth
propagated by the pharmaceutical
industry just so you know anyway a few
more responses someone says LMAO because
there's no way women feel depressed
thanks to this misogynistic society that
makes us powerless of course
someone else posts misogynistic post
love is universal sure maybe masculine
and feminine energies could be more
balanced but like what the f does gender
have to do with strength or feeling
loved we're all the same
now these kinds of rebuttals were
offered an even greater volume and with
greater Fury after a Twitter account
called bad medical takes posted a
screenshot inviting you know further
mockery the funny thing about the bad
medical takes account is that most of
the bad medical takes that they post are
actually pretty good medical takes
and that's the case here so I want to
talk more about the reaction to this
guy's observation there are a few
important points to be make to be made
there I think but I I want to start I
guess by engaging with the actual point
which is what we should do so
is it true
that literally all cases of male
depression can be explained with these
simple one-sentence summary that he
offers is it true that men don't need to
feel loved at all and women don't need
to feel powerful at all is is this
statement a universal 100 applicable
diagnosis of every case of depression in
the entire world no
but I also don't think it was intended
that way it seems to me that he's making
a general observation meant to challenge
current assumptions that people make and
to encourage us to think differently
about a subject that mainstream wisdom
often gets wildly wrong
and to that end there's quite a lot of
value and insight here
first he's acknowledging something that
is usually ignored in this conversation
and in every other conversation which is
that men and women are different and so
they're going to experience depression
differently broadly speaking because
they are different
okay we're all human beings we're all
aware of our own existence and of our
place within a broken world full of pain
and suffering which means that there's
going to be a lot of similarities in our
experiences of depression because that's
where it all ultimately comes from but
it's not going to be exactly the same
because we have different emotional
needs
and the differences are they're a matter
of degree of kind of calibration so it's
not that men have emotional needs that
don't exist at all for women or vice
versa but rather that our priorities
tend to be different and we also tend to
interpret our experiences differently
so an example that's very relevant to
the topic at hand
if a woman is unhappy in her marriage
it's likely because at bottom she
doesn't feel loved and appreciated if a
man is unhappy it's likely because at
bottom he doesn't feel respected now
it's not that she doesn't need respect
or he doesn't need love
it would maybe be more accurate to say
that uh you know maybe you could say
that the best way to love a man is to
respect him and the best way to respect
a woman is to love her
now you might say this is kind of hair
splitting because love and respect in
this context are not too distinct
Inseparable things they are dimensions
of each other
um you can't really love someone if you
don't respect them or respect them if
you don't love them at least not in the
context of a marriage and all that's
true yet it's also true that men are
more likely to interpret their unhappy
marriage in terms of its lack of respect
while women are more likely to interpret
in terms of a lack of love
and they're both right in different ways
acid depression my primary issue with
Smith's take is that he I think he gives
too much credit to the medical industry
actually
he says that they assume that all
depressed people men and women just need
to feel loved I wish that was the
mistake they made I think more often the
assumption is that everyone men and
women alike
simply need not love but just the right
prescription love has nothing to do with
it
but but he's largely right I think from
a cultural perspective
and all you have to do is listen to the
things people say to the monstras
mantras and bumper sticker slogans and
all that they're supposed to make
depressed people feel better you know
things like it's okay to not be okay
you are loved you are special all that
sort of thing it's a very feminine
oriented message
though I suspect that these slogans
don't do much for women either
that first one especially it's okay to
not be okay
projects powerlessness it encourages
almost
and this is a problem because indeed a
great many men in our culture feel
powerless they feel as though they have
no control over their own lives
this is one of the main reasons that so
many men have dropped out of the dating
pool like we talked about yesterday they
fear that marriage is a losing game I
hear this all the time they think that
marriage is rigged against men and that
they'll become even more powerless and
vulnerable than they already are if they
get married
look also at uh at you know in extreme
cases look at men who lash out violently
whether we're talking about drug dealers
on the street corner or School shooters
or whatever the violent Outburst is
among other things a twisted tragic way
of exercising power and control
men who commit suicide are also in their
minds taking control exercising power
over their own faint for what may feel
to them to be the first and last time in
their lives
I said yesterday that men in this
culture
uh suffer from a lack of purpose and
Direction but powerlessness is a key
factor here as well because in order for
a man to find his purpose in order for
him to decide on a direction and walk
down and he first has to feel that he
has the power to do so that he has
control that he has agency over his own
life
you know that stereotypical image of the
depressed jobless guy down in the
basement playing video games all day
this is an image of helplessness of a
man who feels he has no power over his
life
and this is where the actual message
that he gets from the healthcare
providers only makes things worse
by treating depression and despair as
purely medical issues
as a physical disease that can be cured
with a drug we are encouraging the
depressed person whether male or female
to feel powerless
like all they can do is take a pill and
just hope that it saves them and anyone
who encourages lifestyle changes you
know more exercise better diet anyone
who suggests that if you're feeling down
maybe you know you go outside and get
some fresh air and some sunshine
do something with your free time other
than staring at glowing screens all day
anyone who gives the depressed person
things that they can actively do to help
their situation is shouted down that's
because of this powerlessness is
intentionally fostered
the medical industry has found it quite
profitable
to have a country full of powerless
people who think that their only hope
for the future lies in a pill
so there is indeed a lot of Truth in
what Smith has to say despite how it was
received in fact it was received
negatively because there was so much
truth in it
that brings me to my final point
agree or disagree with his opinion
it is at least an interesting thought
okay
a great many thoughts are shared on the
internet every day millions and millions
of thoughts and most of them are not
remotely interesting
and I don't care right now if they're
right or wrong they're not interesting
it's not that the thoughts are all wrong
many of them are but that's not the
point the point is that everyone is
talking the chatter never stops and and
yet most of what's being said is boring
redundant just simply uninteresting
lots of talk very little insight
that's at least in part because this is
what happens to anyone who dares to say
something interesting like you go out on
a limb and you kind of exp Even If
you're sort of like experimenting with
an idea maybe you're thinking out loud a
little bit you're trying to work through
something and uh you know maybe you
haven't even and I'm not saying this is
the case with here but but I mean God
forbid you're just kind of like uh
you're thinking about this and you're
and you're talking through it and the
idea isn't fully formed but you think
you've kind of you're you're walking
down the right direction and so you you
just go out on a limb and you and you
offer your thought
and if you do that you're descended upon
you're ripped apart you're mocked
anyone who Ventures even a few inches
outside the box is belittled by all of
the dull mindless drones Inside the Box
it's the nature of the internet to
encourage these kinds of reactions
because you would never react that way
in real life right if you were sitting
around in a living room having a
conversation and a few drinks and Adam
Lane Smith was there and uh you know you
got to talking about uh depression all
this and he made the point that male
depression often stems from
powerlessness
you wouldn't start shouting at him or
laughing in his face or mocking him with
snide comments unless you are the most
insufferable dork on the planet you
wouldn't respond that's the dumbest
thing I've ever heard [ __ ]
instead you would say something like hmm
that's interesting here's what I think
and the conversation would continue but
on the internet the goal is to score
points right it's not to have a
conversation
certainly not to reach an understanding
the goal if anything is the opposite of
understanding it's to ensure that what
the other person said is not understood
and come to think of it this is all
probably contributing to the problem of
helplessness because it can be rather a
helpless feeling to share a thoughtful
insight and have it mindlessly ripped
apart by stupid pedantic disingenuous
trolls
all the more validation for the point
that Smith raised all the more reason to
say to his critics
not to him
you are today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block
um hope to see you there if not hope to
at least see you out at the rally today
and if not then then on Monday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]